Moya, moey, boo!
Welcome in!
Welcome in, howdy dody!
Hi, hi, hi!
Welcome in, welcome in, howdy, dody!
Welcome back to BioShark!
You are Shark!
BioShark!
Shark!
Moya, moey, boo!
I feel like I should make a moey emo.
I wonder if I should...
Oh, Takizo!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
20 months in, Minky!
Thank you, Andrew!
I wonder if I should...
I was thinking recently maybe redoing some of my emotes.
All of your emotes are Moe emotes.
That's true.
You could...
Instead of a Moe kanji, you could do like...
Just two Aibu.
What would you cut out?
though for my emotes?
Well, I think, hold on, there's like this one and this one,
they're pretty similar, right?
I don't wanna take out all of my 1.0, but some of them
maybe, you know?
No!
One is for extreme crying.
Don't I have so many crying emotes?
Don't I have so many?
Oh yeah, Bulba.
I guess you guys can use it when I drink water, which I'm
doing right now.
Oh my gosh.
It was so...
Today was a lot of stuff for me.
And it was around...
ago i was like i'm so tired and so i made coffee and now i'm
wired i did finish portal i did i did i did um yeah oh it i
it went 90 smooth it was i raged a little bit in the final
boss battle it was my own fault but
I don't know, I guess because I'm so, like, I feel like
there's times when I don't know what to do and I'm like,
huh?
And then there's times I don't know what to do and I'm like,
what do I do?
So, hmm.
Hello, Amito, and I was like, you!
I'm ready to solve some puzzles, cast some bees out of my
hand and save some little sisters!
Yeah!
Do you still hate Wheatley?
No.
Diagonal VTuber moment.
But you know what's worse is like when it's myself.
If it's only just me trying to figure something out.
Well, I can't get it.
I kind of explain it in the...
When I was recording it.
But like sometimes you get tunnel vision.
And you really think that, um, that like, how do you say it?
Like the way that you're doing the puzzle is the way to do
it.
You know what I mean?
So you get tunnel vision because you're just like, you're
like, this is how you do it.
And it's my inability to do it.
That is what is making me not do it correctly.
Not the fact that I'm doing the entire part incorrectly, you
know?
So, um, it's kind of funny though, because I, I struggled on
this one part so much and then literally I went to the
bathroom and I came back and I was like what do I do and
then I see something and I was like let me just try this
maybe it's this and it was literally that sometimes it's
just so stinking stupid I was like what the heck afterwards
because I was getting so tilted by this one part heart.
I was like, what?
What do I do?
And then I was like, maybe I just, I saw something and I was
like, huh.
But maybe I really am dumb moment.
Truly.
Post P clarity.
It's so, it's so funny how sometimes like your brain can
click so easily with a puzzle and then not click.
Like you literally with another puzzle but it's the opposite
for other people like they will struggle so much with the
same puzzle that you clicked with so easily and then and
then piece of cake the other thing it's just oh it's so
funny but we're back to bio shock bio shock oh i was hoping
i this is my own fall i made my own schedule but i was like
oh this is so busy today i just want to relax with the game
but Bioshock is now relaxed and so no we're we will we will
get through it as a science grad let me tell you walking
back into a tough lab after a bio break is the heart of all
scientific epiphany it's it has happened three times now in
my playthrough which is so funny working through the part
three VOD so I'm VOD gang for this one oh thanks for
watching though and thanks for the super chat I'm having
lots of fun with this playthrough thanks for playing mint
hope your night is swell thank you Thank you, thank you.
It's a game for when you're wired.
Bioshock and chill.
I am Zen.
Deep breaths, everybody, in and out.
We are Zen.
Now, well, thank you!
I'm happy to announce I'm having my first holiday after
working five years non-stop.
And four days of Mito's streams is the best I could...
Now, well, please rest!
enjoy your holiday oh my goodness five years five years this
is why i feel bad complaining more bees more bees and i'll
try to remember to take more photos but i'm really bad at
remembering that
oh yeah yeah yeah oh because my name begins with bee and i
love bioshock and you start calling Mr. B.
I'll settle for Mr. Bubbles.
Mr. Bubbles.
Wasn't that the guy's name in Lilo and Stitch?
I have a feeling you'll really enjoy this level.
Smiley face.
You should be getting to Mato's favorite bit soon.
Really?
Yeah.
Cobra Bubbles.
Yeah, his name was Cobra Bubbles.
Yeah, yo, yo.
He had it, like, tattooed on his fingers and everything.
Okay, interesting.
Hmm.
Oh, no, I'm trying not to drink any more of my coffee for
right now.
To be fair, I also kept forgetting to take pictures on my
first playthrough.
Yeah, it's like one of those...
I'm so bit...
I'm like, must kill.
Must kill.
You know.
Okay.
What?
I also remembered something.
I remembered something that I forgot to do.
I forgot on my way back to Arcadia.
I forgot to get the weapon upgrade.
I ran past it.
Yeah, the gun upgrade.
We forgot.
All right.
Bees.
I don't remember where it was, though.
Do you know Winter's Blast slows hacking fluid?
Really?
But I like the thrill.
Today is apparently the 20th anniversary of Metal Gear
Awesome.
No way.
Is the audio on?
Yeah, okay.
Circus of...
3-2-3-2-mini.
Values.
I hear somebody.
3-2-mini.
Not in here.
Hey, don't just stand there.
Come on, man.
Please.
I gotta go find the weapons.
She looks so tired.
I'm ready for dream.
Oh.
Does he pick her up?
Oh, oh.
No.
perhaps we'll dine on ham and jammies she's so cute baby
thank you love watching you hack no one lays pipe like you
mean though thank you just call me mario actually don't call
me that
okay um let me maybe it's on the map Zoom out.
I have no idea.
More of a Luigi.
I don't remember where it was.
I'm trying to think.
Mint Luigi.
The map is still very special.
The map is like impossible to follow.
Whoever created this is just...
Oh, zoom out is the bottom left or right!
Wow!
I thought it was with a scroll wheel.
That's why I was like, huh?
It's not listed on the map.
Oh my gosh, that sucks.
Mario Day and Minto Day are the same day, so it checks out.
You're right!
I hate that.
Can I be Princess Rosalina?
Yeah.
You can.
She's so awesome.
One of the worst maps ever...
Like, what the hell is this?
It's egregious.
This should be an arrestable offense, honestly.
This is so bad.
You can walk by Big Daddy is really close.
Starting your new job!
Bad news.
Less time for me, though.
No!
New job is great!
Congratulations, original bridge house!
Congratulations!
Um, okay.
Does anyone want to give me, if anybody remembers, if anyone
wants to give me a hint as to where it was.
That kind of upgrade.
It was close to...
Hold on, wait.
Um.
Yeah, back towards the farmer's market.
Yes, let's go to the farmer's market then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I think I remember...
Burr, maybe.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Okay, it's gonna be barely confusing.
Not following the arrow.
Okay, okay, I know where I am.
Ooh, I thought it hurt somebody.
Okay, farmer's market.
Bees.
Hey, hey, you're supposed to die to the bees!
Okay, Farmers Market is not...
Wait, no.
Not that way.
The pain.
Farmers Market, I saw a sign.
Okay, I think I go back through here.
Farmers Market.
She's still here!
Okay.
Um...
Okay, it was like right here, I'm pretty sure.
I knew it, I knew it.
Um, okay, cool.
Maybe I get the machine gun kickback reduction, I think.
I think that might be the way to go.
I got the damage increase.
So I think the kickback, because I've been using it, would
be better.
Always shotgun or machine gun first.
I love my little pistol, though.
We'll do the kickback reduction, though, I think.
Whoa, whoa.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, no.
Wait, what did I just do?
Did it do it right?
Wait, uh-oh.
My cursor glitched out.
I don't actually know what I clicked.
I hope that worked.
Wait.
It looks like it worked, right?
Yeah, it looks like it worked, right?
It worked, okay.
Yeah, my...
Sometimes the game...
Okay, so like...
You see how my cursor is going over there?
Sometimes it will click out of the game.
To, you know, like...
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Well, you know what?
Whatever, it's fine.
Holy shit, that's such a difference.
Wow, there's like no kickback at all.
That's crazy.
Wow.
I'm so rich.
I need to spend my money at the circus of values.
This is reduction, but it didn't say like no more.
Hacked.
Okay, good.
I'm gonna use you and then...
No!
Oh, God.
Wait, this is making the game unplayable.
It just clicked out of the game again.
Uh-oh, okay.
I might need to restart the game.
Did it...
Did it buy it?
Yes, okay, it did.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Yeah, more like recoil delete.
Yeah, for real.
Are they still over here?
Where'd they go?
Oh!
Really?
Why are you in here?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Don't be slow.
No!
Living core, thank you so much for the vibe!
Get did!
Yeah, I'm gonna save just in case.
Alright, here we go.
Attack?
Oh, take a picture!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Oh!
Shoot!
Oh my god!
Why is it doing this today?
I just accidentally minimized the window.
Oh, no, no, no.
Uh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, why is it doing this today?
Okay, hold on.
I'm...
Yeah, I'm gonna restart the window and see it.
Oh, it did it again!
Some people are saying I can take up to three, so I'll start
doing that.
Okay.
I'm gonna save.
And then restart.
Oh no!
Why is it like this?
Okay, quit.
I have to run the game in Windows, you guys.
You don't understand.
It's one of those old games that if I don't run it in
Windows, like in Windows mode, it uh, in Windows.
In Windows mode, it, like, ruins my entire, like,
Everything, like all the windows on my screen become like
crazy.
So I have to do it in windowed mode.
Yeah, it's going to mess with my monitor settings.
Yeah, it's kind of annoying.
But it is what it is.
We.
I deal with it all the time.
window in windows wild hello is it gonna load oh okay all
right
this is one of those things
whoa whoa the textures are loading in i think
Why is it?
Does it look funky to anybody else?
Or is it just me?
Alright, can you like...
Can you guys leave, please?
It looks blurry, right?
What's going on?
Wait, why does it look like I need glasses?
What's happening?
Because I have the camera equipped.
Oh, thank you.
I was like, what the heck?
Alright, can we like leave, please?
Oh my god.
I don't want to, I don't know what's going to happen in
here, so I don't want to like...
I'm ready for dream time.
Okay, screw it.
No.
Nice!
Please!
Don't attack me.
Here, go away.
Go away.
Okay.
Deploy the Lazarus Vector!
Listen to Sam take care of a crank.
It seems Julie's death didn't provide Oh.
What do you mean this?
What is this?
Seal up the entrance.
I'm gonna be stuck with these bozos.
Are they still in here?
Oh my god.
Okay, well it's not like we're in a rush or anything.
Okay.
How is there dirt coming in, huh?
Please move.
Please go!
Actually, wait, I have an idea.
Um, which one was it?
Uh, you.
I'm trying!
Where's the lab entrance?
Oh, shoot.
That doesn't look good.
How do I seal it?
How do I seal this?
Oh, seal.
Seal?
Seal the door.
I did.
It's closed?
Defend
me, buddy.
Defend me.
Uh...
Open the new mall.
Oh, I didn't even see what was in here.
Oh, nice.
Alright, you're gonna defend me again?
He's all covered in goop.
Alright, um...
Woo!
Do they?
Wait, where are they?
Oh.
I'll just stand here in the corner.
You do your job.
I can't shoot him though.
What's going on?
Oh, I think he's like right behind me.
Oh, oh, no, don't shoot me!
Show him!
Yeah, good job!
I'm holding my own.
What's going on?
Everything is chaos!
Ouch!
Don't shoot me!
Everything... I think I've found the best option to do this.
Maybe.
Just sit in the corner.
Put baby in the corner.
It really is chaos in here.
I need your help.
Ouch!
I don't want to shoot because I'm scared.
Oh, oh my god, no.
Um, sorry.
It clicked out of the window again.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, no, please!
Oh.
Yeah, good job, Big Daddy.
Bioshock Y.
Oh, Bioshock Y.
Yeah, kill his ass.
Get his ass.
I don't know what...
I can't see anything right now.
Everything is crazy in this.
Everything...
Where are you going?
No, no, you're mine!
Help me!
I can't shoot you're scared maybe I can do this oh shoot no
oh my god where's that daddy go is he doing anything his
best yeah he's doing his best ah oh my god oh my god sorry
oh this is okay guys sorry I'm having a I'm struggling I
moved over and it does that you know that thing and oh my
god we're like in shows the windows all disappear on your
screen.
Oh, what's happening today?
Oh my gosh.
Halfway!
What do you mean I'm halfway?
Whoa!
Halfway!
What?
Okay, uh, what was my goal now?
No, Akar, I'm so sorry, you guys.
I don't know if this is playable.
I don't know what the issue is today.
My cursor is completely out of the game now.
Oh, my gosh.
Wave 2.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know why it's...
Doing this, though.
Yeah, you can see.
my cursor at the top, right?
It's like going craziness.
I don't know why it was fine until just today, though.
Just play the game.
No, I'm trying to explain to you that it keeps clicking out
of the game and makes it so I can't play it.
That's why I'm having a hard time.
You're not mad at me, right?
Big Daddy, okay, good.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
When did you wake back up?
We're gonna back into the corner method.
Good thing I filled up on my house.
Holy cow.
I think I'm, like, so screwed.
Big Daddy is great, but he's not perfect.
Did you just throw a grenade at me?
Uh-oh.
I didn't hit you, right, Big Daddy?
Oh, you love me so.
Help!
Big Daddy!
It's just a whole bunch of dead people here.
Big Daddy, help!
Oh.
Big...
Oh!
The door's shut just in time.
Big Daddy, get that guy out.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's stupid again.
He's not my friend anymore.
Hold on, I'm gonna save again.
PC can have its drawbacks.
Yeah, only on older games really.
Okay, we go back.
Is everyone else dead?
they are not I hurt do I need to go in there oh were they
just chilling in here oh my gosh who's shooting at me I
don't even see them
where are you oh my god so funny i'm bleeding oh he went to
go use the health thing well too bad i hacked that bozo okay
now there's like so much to collect huh we can take all
their money and buy all the i'm i'm full on money again okay
the circus of value all right Yippee!
Let's go take all their money.
I was so focused on using
Big Daddy for help that I forgot that I could be him.
I could just send my bees.
Holy cow.
Oh, I should have searched before I bought anything, huh?
Wait, can I take the money?
I should have searched before I bought anything.
My bad.
Oh well.
I have so much money.
Then I'll get it all back.
Hello.
La la la la la.
Yeah.
Oh.
Lock box searched.
Searched.
Can I search these guys?
Hi.
More stuff.
More money.
So much money.
Holy cow.
You got money?
Oh yeah!
Okay, now we can go.
Hey, hey, hey.
Chill out.
I'm not here for you.
So much money.
Yahoo!
Adam, on the other hand.
Yeah, Adam is a...
Help.
I don't know.
I feel like I could take on Big Daddy here.
I could try.
Yeah, I still have one little sister.
Where is he?
Oh, they're in here.
Hmm.
All those proximity mines?
Uh, wait.
Ah, look how cute they're being!
What's his health at?
It's like a quarter of the way down.
Wait, I think he's putting her away.
No!
I was too slow.
Let's do this first.
See what happens.
I mean, this room has nothing going on in it, so we surely
will have to go back out, right?
So I imagine then...
Um...
Then we...
Uh, we have to go back all the way through here, no?
The trees are alive!
Wow!
Whoa!
Time for blood.
Bit of backtracking at some point.
That's okay.
I don't mind that.
One thing that, um...
Wait.
Oh, oh, she's back, she's back, she's back.
All right, here we go.
Fighting this guy.
One thing that I really like about this game, actually,
is...
Oh, shoot.
Sorry, I just did that again.
I've grown older today.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Just bowls.
Happy birthday!
Mr. Grotto, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
One thing I like about this game is that...
It doesn't feel like I'm like...
It doesn't... Like, each area feels pretty fresh, which I
like, you know.
Okay, I just saved, okay.
Is he affected by the bees?
Is he affected by bees?
Oh yeah, another picture.
Let's grab one before I...
Kill him.
Bayroid.
Alright.
Oh, alright.
Alright, alright.
I'm scared.
Sorry, I'm like...
Fighting him stresses me out.
My proximity mines?
Deployed?
This angel looks like...
What is a sound?
Holy cow!
I was pressing B and not pressing F.
Holy cow.
Oh my god!
I was pressing B and not pressing F.
Okay, we did it, though.
We saved both sisters.
Yeah, those mines were crazy.
Thank you, Mr. Oh my god, the bow is too cute.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
And there she goes.
Wait.
Oh, she doesn't count, I guess.
Okay, never mind.
Yippee!
Uh, there was something I was going to do.
Um...
Oh, nice.
I'll take that for sure.
And... that for sure.
Nice.
Oh, he broke my machine.
That's why there were two...
Okay.
Uh...
Let's all remember.
Yeah, let's save.
sisters don't count got it got it okay uh what was i gonna
do i had it in my head oh i remember there were more oh
actually i didn't run over here and grab these huge okay
there was uh at the front of the lab there were some more um
in here that's what i wanted the proximity mines okay cool
Baby, oh, it just happened.
Oh, it clicked out of my game.
No, wait, where did my game go?
Okay, just kidding.
We're fine.
This is so scuffed.
It's kind of funny watching Minto be afraid of fighting big
daddies.
I consider the Metal Gear bosses to be more difficult.
Really?
Bees.
I wish they hated my bees more.
These guys take a lot of damage.
No!
I'm pressing all the wrong buttons today.
What's wrong with me?
Do they have more...
More machine gun rounds.
We'll take that.
Big daddies are more ungabunga approach.
You think so?
Alright, let's go.
We're heading this way.
Okay, that's what I figured.
Now where's your gun?
I can't carry any more pistol rounds.
Too many pistol rounds.
Take the money though.
Sounds like monkeys in here.
Can't pick up that.
Is that somebody's purse?
I wish to rob.
I wish to steal the money.
Why are you so resistant to the traditional methods of
separating a man from his soul?
You're not CIA, are you?
You belong to the Atlas.
The one roach I can't seem to exterminate.
Matarakan?
Yeah, me too.
Are these fish?
Where are we now?
A gift?
I believe in no God, no invisible man in the sky.
But there is something more powerful than each of us.
A combination of our efforts, a great chain of industry that
unites us.
But it is only when we struggle in our own interest that the
chain pulls society in the right direction.
The chain is too powerful and too mysterious for any
government.
Mysterious.
Any man who tells you different.
Either has his hand in your pocket, or a pistol to your
neck.
Wait, there's so many places.
Point Prometheus.
Oh.
Cohen's collections.
No tunes?
Oh, I thought that was a person there.
Okay.
Let's go!
We're going to...
Fort Frolic?
I suppose?
Looks kind of sexy.
Is that why it's the best area?
Game saved.
Yahoo!
I feel, oh wow, I feel like last stream had I known that.
If I had known that I didn't have so much left, I would
have...
I didn't understand.
The Fortune teller!
Where is it?
I can't hear you, everybody's speaking.
Sla!
Oh no!
I want to use the Fortune teller.
What's my fortune.
Believe me when I tell you.
I don't want to be in your shoes.
even why am I so tiny oh
no way apples apples apples we're all apples oh we're Oh, it
feels so good, the hack.
Oh, yeah, baby, it feels so good, the hack.
Feels so good, the hack.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give me more.
Give me.
Oh, this is the event thing.
Oh, I don't like this one, actually.
This one does stress me out a little bit.
Because I feel like they want very specific things for this
one, you know.
Minto, remember not to exasperate your gambling problem.
Exacerbate.
I'm not doing any baiting.
I'm doing a little healthy dose of gambling.
And I also hate gambling.
Don't get me wrong, YouTube.
What's a trap bolt?
Tripwire bolts for the crossbow?
Hackers delight.
Oh, wait.
Boozhound.
Drinking alcohol restores a small amount of Eve rather than
draining it.
Bloodlust.
You gain small amounts of health in Eve when inflicting
damage with the ranch.
that's a that's bait to try and get me to use the ranch you
need to remember that most gamblers quit before hitting it
big i hit it big i got 25 bucks what do you want from me
he's seeking rpg see remember all that distilled water that
i was like i don't know if i need this it was a good idea
25 bucks that's Look, I have so much money that I can
barely...
That I can barely...
Use all of it.
It's Nico time!
Nico time!
That's kind of actually clever.
Instead of like Nico teen.
Nico time.
Good speech on the gunbat.
Just do not follow up with any baby noises.
Nico, Nico, ni!
Alright.
You.
How do we have flies in here?
I think our stuff that we're bringing in from the surface is
contaminated and disgusting.
To show how much we hate gambling, we are going to rob these
slot machines from all their chips.
Yeah!
I'm blind!
Apothecary.
Plasmid quick.
Oh, oh nice.
I'm guessing if I like...
I did a little crime.
Now that is just dirty.
Who's even manning these things any- oh, yous?
Ah, I sure wish I had a pretty little lady to dance with me.
Alright, we- atrium.
I'm just exploring right now.
Oh, there's the bot shut down.
Oh, classic.
Oh.
I'll come back for that if I need it.
I will eventually.
Aw, man.
Come back, the apple.
Eve's garden.
Alright.
Oh, we're back in the bathosphere?
We're not back in the bathosphere.
Oh.
Actually, what is happening?
Whoa!
Whoa, what's going on?
Ah, that's better.
Atlas Ryan.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Time was.
You could get something decent on the radio.
The artist has a duty to seduce the eel.
and delight the spirit.
So say goodbye to those two blowhards and hello to an
evening with Sander Cohen.
Sander Cohen.
Ooh, la la.
I haven't seen a sign of real life down here in months.
Let's see if you're just another Johnny Cup lately.
Oh my god, I hear more.
But I don't know where from.
Where?
I hear them, but I don't know from where.
Are they above me?
Oh, what are they doing?
Oh my god.
The bees.
Are they up above me?
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god.
Bees!
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to reload.
Okay, she died by that.
Alright.
You just get them one at a time.
Yeah!
The bees are awesome.
I can smell the malt and vinegar in this one.
I've waited so long for something tasty to come to this
little burg.
are yoke rules and rules where are my manners come in come
in sander kohan awaits you at the fleet hall the fleet hall
wait where oh i'm trying to get her excuse me excuse me do
you have nothing
did those break it's really cool to get the health kits now
Hello?
Oh, what did I just do?
This is the part, right?
I guess I can't.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
I get it wrong every time.
Oh,
that one's not broken.
This one, this one has glass.
Who will let me take it?
Rude.
Okay, whatever.
the circus of values no free stuff allowed no free stuff
allowed yeah i could break the glass it looks like it was
broken though no oh shoot it's what it is okay uh oh wait
we're we lost before we even started
before we even started.
Rip erroneous.
Yeah, bad roll.
That's why I saved before them because otherwise it's
like...
That's not my fault.
That's not my skill being bad, you know?
That's the game being unfair a little bit.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
game please game game game game game no i did the wrong
thing uh okay bees
rpg random pipe generation i love i love it but it is it is
tough sometimes oh come on wait it's going to go down this
way so uh can i get one that goes to the This one?
Yes.
Oh, no!
Are you kidding me right now?
Come on!
I do have ways...
I like how tough it can be though.
I like doing it without any help of anything.
I think it's really fun.
Okay.
There we go.
Uh, buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh.
Okay, uh, up and over and over and I just need one more
over.
There we go.
Freezing it is cool, IMO.
Well, you're free to do that and I'm free to hack it.
I please?
I feel like a baby at my first casino.
Apples, apples, apples!
Apples, apples!
Whoa, whoa!
Welcome to Fort Frolic.
Fort Frolic.
What did you do to them?
oh oh my god oh good they were boring yeah they were
annoying the artist yes the artist knows there is richer
earth to tell unlock for example oh I test you little moth
but for a reason I test all my disciples some shy like
galaxies and some some burn like I'll come now into my home
cool I'm really concerned about that though ninky moth I'm
really I think that's a pretty bad thing why can't I even
try to unlock this it won't even let me attempt it Medical
expert too.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, it's opening up other programs.
Where am I?
Oh shoot.
There we go.
When it tabs out at least it pauses the game.
That is so true.
That is like my one saving grace.
Is it centered to your monitor?
And also, it won't let me move it.
I...
Oh my god, please!
I've been dealing with a very scuff setup.
I am.
I'm dealing with a very scuff setup.
I just deal with it.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Please!
I don't know why it's so bad today.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, uh...
I need to go down.
Down.
Down, down.
them by the...
Seriously?
I have no other way to solve this.
There was literally no other way to solve it!
Ah!
It's okay.
We load.
Act okay.
This one was...
This one did not stay hacked or stay down for a very long
time at all.
Even though I hacked it.
I did not sit down for a very long time at all.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all
right.
Oh!
No!
This is cruel!
This is so cruel!
Okay.
That's not, you're not playing by the rules!
You're not playing by the rules!
I'm not playing by the rules!
Little game.
I don't mind, honestly, I don't mind having to restart it.
I kind of just enjoy, I just enjoy like, I kind of enjoy
doing it like over and over again, you know what I mean?
Like it's kind of...
Oh my god, it's another one where I'm supposed to know from
the very beginning that I need to go a different way!
Okay.
I find it relaxing.
Rigged.
Yeah, I enjoy the hacking so much.
Hacking minigame is me too far.
Okay, uh...
Uh...
You.
Oh!
No!
Yes, yes, yes.
And then...
Um...
You.
And then...
Hello?
Oh, you.
There we go.
I...
Will do my best to play as much as I can with how the game
is today.
I don't know why it's acting up.
Maybe I just needed to restart my whole computer or
something.
I'll do my best to, you know...
Play as much as I can tolerate with how the game is.
Yeah.
It's just a little annoying.
But I'm dealing.
I'm dealing.
I'll try not to complain so much about it.
But it does kind of catch me off guard when I...
When it does happen, you know what I mean?
Wait,
can I get through here?
Oh, I can't.
I just realized.
Oh.
Ow.
Yeah, it's not intended, so it really catches me off guard.
The toughest part about it is, like, I can't tell.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is evil.
I didn't even have the...
part that i needed okay we'll redo this um you're very
unwelcome to the circus of value no i always win i brute
force my way i brute force my way i can do it
oh yeah what the hell oh i wonder if i should do the ones up
top first since I'm doing the ones...
I just try to give myself a little you know, a little extra
time, you know?
Okay, no, uh, this is fine, this is fine, this is fine.
Please,
uh...
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot,
I always win.
What do we got here anyway?
The circus of value!
I will buy those.
I will pick that up.
I will search those.
You see what I'm dealing with here?
Look at my mouse at the top!
Okay.
Wait, why did I stop?
Wait.
Hello?
Wait, why am I frozen?
What's happening?
What a moment.
I think everything is shutting down.
What's going on?
I think today is not in the cards.
What is happening?
Oh my god.
I don't know what's happening.
Oh, am I back?
No.
It's penance for save scumming.
Oh, I thought I was back for a second.
The circus is rejecting.
My cheating!
I'm not cheating!
If I restart my PC, I have to make a whole new stream.
Let me see.
Uh, what's going on?
What is happening?
I don't know why.
It's being so funky today.
Um...
Uh...
Let's see what's hogging everything.
Nothing.
My CPU is at 30%.
Memory is at 40%.
I don't... It says like Firefox is taking up most of my
stuff, which must be like the streaming thing, because I
have basically no tabs open.
oh goodness gracious what's going on okay i think i think i
don't know what's happening uh let me okay i did just save
didn't i let me save again oh my god wait how could i save
there we go oh goodness gracious what's going on this is so
strange this is My everything is bugging out right now.
So I will quit the game.
Oh, I can't quit the game.
Wait, quit the game.
And that did not solve anything.
I think everything is bugging out.
What's going on?
Okay, guys.
I think I'm just...
I think everything is haunted.
I will try to come back with another stream.
about everything.
I know that it's like not super important that I'm moving.
But it, everything is going wrong.
Today is cursed.
I'll try to come back.
We'll do a part two.
Ozovito.
Goodbye.
Wait, can't I like keep the stream?
Wait a second.
Can't I keep the stream going?
As long as OBS...
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna try and keep the stream on.
And then I'll test, and then I'll see if it works.
So I might be back.
We'll see.
Hello.
Hello, wow.
Um.
Uh, I don't know if it's streaming.
Hello.
Oh.
As you can see, I am not moving.
I thought maybe.
I thought maybe TP-Bito would work.
But unfortunately, no.
Uh.
If you guys don't mind me not moving, I'm okay to keep
playing the game.
It seemed like the stream was fine.
I don't even need to be on the screen.
I could even be gone.
If we're okay with me, a true let's play or moment or
something, I don't know.
I'm fine with still playing the game.
Let me start up the game again.
It's okay?
Okay, cool.
Oh,
my mouse is...
You can see it at the top, right?
It's doing the thing still, though.
Oh, it's so funky.
I'm...
I would like to play for at least, like, another hour.
So...
So it doesn't feel like I was a waste, you know?
Yeah.
I did restart my computer.
Let me turn off my camera.
Since it's not connecting anyway.
Maybe my resolution got funky.
I don't know.
Everything's funky.
Try controller.
I don't want to.
I think I don't want to learn how to...
All the controls on the controller.
This far into the game.
Alright.
Alright, alright, we're back, baby.
Is it lonely?
Without me?
Oh.
Oh, it's a big old circle.
Wait, it's telling me to, like, go this way, but then it
tells me to go another way.
What's up here anyway?
Oh.
I don't like the water.
It's lonely?
Don't be lonely.
I feel like I'm back on my let's play era.
I do watch some people that like don't use what's it called
like don't have cameras on right I miss me though sometimes
I think I can still hear her I'm not used to being able to
see the bottom right corner of the screen it scares me look
at all the real estate you have now have you tried
threatening your computer with a hammer or a magnet hey
computer yeah but my computer is filled with Koharu so it's
so cute My name is Micah Plyer and today we are playing
Bioshock.
Is that how Markiplier starts his videos?
I actually never really watched him.
It's kind of lonely.
What?
Should I buy?
Incinerate?
Set objects and creatures.
Wait.
Winter Blast?
two.
Everything is two.
So I could even get more bugs?
We don't become invisible.
My name.
Bugs.
Baga.
More bugs.
Watch at 480p for the real experience.
What should I get?
Maybe...
I haven't been using the incinerate very much, so maybe I
get some bees.
Ended with minky.
Minky plier is my new ocean.
Oh.
Wait, I need a...
I need a...
Oh boy, what a floor show.
Every night.
I need the bank.
Game of chance.
Oh, Jinbank.
It's like it knew what I asked for.
Oh, oh.
Wait, did I do it?
Oh, it did it on its own.
Easy peasy.
What engineering things do I even have?
Oh, the duration of alarms.
Two fewer overload tiles when hacking.
I have been using a hacking thing!
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
be sure to smash that like button and lick the subscribe
button
why are all the circus of values so tough right now i know
it's i see you i see you trying to click out of my game i
see you trying to click out licky licky just like my cat
that's all she does is licky licky Lucky, lucky.
I need you to go this away.
This away.
And, uh...
Wait, no, no, no, no, no.
That was a mistake.
Don't listen to me.
You saw...
This!
I'm sorry, this is two less things!
This is two less!
Only the pure of heart.
You can see Minto's avatar.
It's not an avatar, it's my literal face!
It's because you guys don't have enough spiritual ability.
Oh, you can't see the ghost.
Oh, come on.
Oh, come on!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, we can save this.
We can save this.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
I need another up.
Upies?
Uh, yes.
And no.
Yippee!
Do,
do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, the
circus.
Everybody?
What do you, what is it called?
The circus of value.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I forgot I have the search again!
I'm a little rat.
Wait, how do I search again?
Wait, how does it work?
Did I search again?
Did it work?
Ooh, what's going on in Rapture?
It did already.
Oh, dang.
Oh, that's the one I hacked.
Okay, cool.
Again.
Oh, Diane.
Well, Steinman worked on me, but it was never the same since
the blast.
We being alone so much, guess a girl, time to think.
Who could hate me so much?
They'd ruin me like this.
What did I do to them?
You know, I keep thinking of all them bandits and
terrorists.
Ryan's got locked up in Paula Square and I get so mad.
Sometimes I can hardly breathe.
What is a bedtime surprise?
If I could only confront them.
Casey, thank you so much!
Thank you!
I'm ruining everything for me!
For rapture.
Maybe I...
Maybe I feel better.
Hello.
Jasmine.
Are we gonna see Jasmine, Jolene?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, is this supposed to be like that?
Or is this the game...
No, I think the game games being funky.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, you can only search again if you don't loot it.
Ah, got it, got it.
Alright.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, baby.
Alright, yeah.
Give Minto what she needs.
Which is a long boy.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, oh, okay.
Go in the absolute most roundabout way we possibly can go.
But it works.
Yeah!
Search again!
Oh, funny how when I fix it, it works properly.
So funny, huh?
How that works?
hilarious yeah i agree
oh you can't see me i'm dancing you can't tell i'm dancing
for who for what what am i doing insult of all the worthy
artists in rapture why you continue to devote column inches
to this musical gremlin is beyond my imagination musical
gremlin she's not derivative she's boring where she's not
boring she's obvious where she's not obvious she's dangerous
dangerous i like him he's funny
Where she's not obvious, she's dangerous.
The you vent.
This one should be doable, right?
Break him.
We're gonna give... Oh!
We're gonna give you ones that are possible.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just looking around real quick.
This place is big!
He's quite the character.
Hi, welcome to Mambusha, thank you!
Alright, let's go back to where it told me to go.
What is it?
Interesting, it's very...
Oh, I can't go in here, yeah, okay, just kidding.
What an ornate door, right?
Search again?
Wow!
It worked!
Search again?
Nothing.
This one I can't search, okay?
Could this be a metal gear reference?
Wait.
What do you possibly think I would meet with my public now
when I'm preparing unbelievable?
Oh, there he is.
Mr. I got something really cool to show you.
What the heck just happened?
Unbelievable.
I got something really cool to show you though.
Oh, come on.
Oh, it even heals!
Okay, I'm just kidding.
Alright.
Is this a puzzle?
Oh, wait.
Called the elevator.
beach.
It's here.
Yeah, I know I barely...
Whoa, this is...
Oh, no.
I'm coming in!
Ready or not!
Oh, I'm bouncing, but you can't tell.
Allegro, Allegro.
Oh my god, these chairs and tables are perfect size for me.
I should probably say.
I
think she's doing alright though.
Literally me.
Me trying to do anything on stream.
No, VTuber, no, no, no.
I'm trying.
Wait, I saw something.
Oh, potato chips.
Oh, my God.
Death.
The burden of the artist is to capture.
See young Fitzpatrick here on the stage.
Yeah, you got anything?
Take him as he is now.
So I may remember him.
Damn.
Photograph the dead people.
Okay.
I'll get his good side.
What are you waiting for?
Fitzpatrick can't hold that pose forever.
I said it the right way.
That's how you're supposed to say it, no?
And now you've got Fitzpatrick caught in his moment of
glory.
It seems you've got the eye of the shutterbug.
Oh, thank you.
Now head to the atrium and place his eyes.
photograph in my masterpiece and so our collaboration
commences okay i like going he's funny oh the house lights
are up shows over i guess boom uh wait this way oh do i go
up around hoop oh oopsie my bad wait what's around here
Oh, wait, uh-oh, wait.
I saw them at the last second, but I saw them.
Eventually.
Having a bit of pianist envy.
You know, I do prefer when people say pianist.
But I think pianist is the proper way of saying it,
technically.
Wait.
I'm sorry, this was not there before.
Oh,
jeez.
I enjoy piano player myself.
Oh, man.
Okay, wait.
I wish I could unleash the bees.
Ouch, I'll jump.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Chill, we're chill.
Hold on.
If I do this...
Okay.
Tank it?
Yeah, I'm trying to get at least one down so then I can take
out the other one.
There we go.
Actually, I'm going to save again.
The turret doesn't have true.
Ah!
No!
Hack!
I'm hacking something!
Oh,
it's so funny.
Oh, I need more.
Please.
Wait, I need this one.
Thank you.
And then this one.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, it's up there.
Oh!
Do I have enough?
Yes!
Don't start with me.
Actually, I'm safe because I already did that.
I'm in.
Hacker voice.
My hacker voice.
I'm in.
What is the hacker voice anyway?
Oh, shoot.
I have to go super roundabout.
Okay.
No, wait.
No, no, no, no.
No.
This is unsolvable.
Oh my god.
No!
That's why I'm not.
be saved i had to go
voice of a hacker wouldn't it then be hacker's voice but no
they say hacker voice i'm in hacker voice i can't say it
though i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not
in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in
i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in i'm not in
I feel like we need like a hacker music.
I'll do it.
Hacker!
Lay the pipe, lay the pipe, lay the pipe, lay the pipe,
hacker!
Hacker voice, hacker voice, hacker voice, I'm here!
Okay, they're my friends now.
Doesn't that just like kind of, it really sets the tone,
right?
It's really like a...
It shows how much urgency and everything.
Oh, more!
Hack it!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You can't do that to me.
Hacker!
Hacker boys!
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
I already lost.
I'll try it one more time.
Hacker voice, hacker voice, hacker voice.
Oh, wait!
No, no, it was already ha- it was all- Oh, wait, oh.
My mouse.
It was rigged from the start.
Am I dead?
No, close to.
It was rigged from the start.
Hacker voice, hacker voice.
I think if actually a song like that played while I was
doing the hacking, I might- I might request a refund.
I think I would be like, I'm no.
I would be like, this is not okay.
This is not okay.
I think something is wrong with my eyes.
You're invisible.
I'm invisible.
Look at you, Hacker.
A pathetic creature of a meat and bone.
Saves are really hard to hack.
But it's kind of fun.
The thrill, no?
Sorry to hear you're having issues with the mouse.
Me, though, the remaster gets super unstable when you play
it on monitor above 1080p.
Posted a possible fix.
Oh, thank you!
I know so many people have, like, suggested, like, certain
programs and things that will allow you to play games in,
like, a certain windowed mode that you can control and
things like that.
And honestly, at this point, I should look into it and
invest into it, you know, but for future stuff as well.
I can't remember.
There was one thing that people suggested last time.
And it's not a matter of me being lazy about it.
It's a matter of I always forget.
I forget what the names of the programs are, and I forget
to...
to install them.
Old games aren't meant to see computers like what we have.
But...
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyway.
Ah, oh, shoot.
No!
I was given nothing.
I'm given.
Not crap.
Oh my god.
No.
My mouse.
No auto-hack.
One second, though.
Before I continue, I will say, I will do a little.
I am not on the screen because my computer hates me.
and I was having issues thank you you can't die the hack
damage it takes you to 1 HP and you stay there no way really
all right resume wait oh resume there we go
wait oh wait wait oh wait oh
I didn't notice in time.
Please don't be...
Okay, okay.
Uh, uh.
Wait, so if I hack again, I won't die.
No.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
The game.
Oh, it's unsolvable.
Oh wow, I don't die for real!
Okay, but I need you to go there.
I need you to go here.
And you to go here.
Okay, wait.
And you go down.
And you to there.
And uh, and uh, you there!
Woo!
Yeah, baby!
We did it!
Yes, uh...
Nice.
I love doing it with my own, like, you know.
So it keeps one in there now, right?
Yeah, okay.
With my own intellect.
My own pure skill.
Okay.
F5.
Was it always F5?
Maybe it was.
Search again.
huge the circus of alleys I did not hack this when I came in
oh my god all of them you know what I get it though at the
same time I just loved it instead of saved um if the hacking
is like taking a long time um I get it.
No!
We lost the bullet!
I get it though.
I get like using the auto because it does take a while.
I can.
Yeah, it's like super RNG and I can see it like getting kind
of frustrating for, you know, some people who are just like,
I just want to play the game.
But for me...
Oh Movie!
Oh that, that!
Oh my god.
Wait, please just give me the part that I need!
Thank you.
Okay for me I really enjoy the puzzly aspect so I don't mind
it so much.
This is the game!
Exactly.
Maybe I didn't come down here.
Oh!
Someone in here?
Okay, so we need to go...
Go this way.
We have a...
Whoa!
Please.
Don't hit me.
Wait, where'd the power go?
Move your own cannons.
One you'll paint with the blood of a man.
I'm... yes, I'll send you.
But first, you must be part of the...
I don't know where I'm going.
Go to the atrium.
Hurry now.
My muse is a fickle bitch with a very short attention span.
My muse.
Where?
Oh, wow!
This is what they'll point to.
Oh, it's lovely.
My masterpiece.
Go ahead.
Don't be afraid.
Touch it.
Touch it?
Oh my gosh, it's a hands-on museum?
You're allowed to touch the art?
Break it!
No!
Press R to load your weapon.
Use.
Oh, I put it in.
He gives me a crossbow!
Oh!
Wow
Bye Three men All connected by a common threat Does the
crossbow is it good in this game?
And immortalize their mortality In my quad Go Once they've
been sent
It's shooting at somebody.
All right.
So I have to go find more men and take their picture.
I have to find three more men and take their picture.
So the first one was in Fleet Hall.
So I assume that we do not need to go into there again.
What about over here?
Poseidon Plaza is now open.
My Morse.
I kind of love him.
What's happening?
Why are they all attacking each other?
Oh, shoot.
That's me.
Plankety, plank, plank.
These.
of them fighting.
I'm so bad at getting the pictures, man.
I swear.
The gents.
And the dames.
This is so...
This guy is so fallout, isn't he?
Mr. Fallout.
John Fallout.
Alright, so he said the Poseidon area, but...
I'm exploring a little bit.
This area is huge.
Okay.
What do I hear?
Oh, I guess it's the lighting.
He's making a sound.
First aid kit, I don't need.
Oops, sorry.
Oh.
Money, money.
Oh, oh, oh, whoa.
Delicious.
Don't like that.
I really don't.
like that um is this one of the guys maybe wrong one
no okay thought he might be wild bunny want
to take the ears off but i can't i hop and when i hop i
never get off the ground oh it's my curse my eternal curse
this poem sucks to take the ears off but i can't it's my
curse it's my fucking curse i want to take the ears off
please take them off please and the scene okay oh yeah
that's funny i i am a by and I wish to hop, but I cannot.
Hop.
Go, Sherry!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
What's in here?
Cocktail lounge.
Oh, what's in here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, I'm gonna get copyright struck!
Holy, that was...
Zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip, zip,
zip, zip, zup, zip, zup, zip, zup.
Uh, no, wait, why am I doing the tune of it?
Somewhere!
Not!
Oh, wait, um...
Somewhere!
On the land!
My lover's stand!
And...
Hack and hack.
Okay, sorry.
no no why are you still going see somewhere but it's so like
tempting to sing you know it's so fun oh wait oh sorry
i can't sing the song what's wrong with me i just can't help
it though blah blah blah blah blah i don't want to get dmced
Oh!
I know!
Beyond the South!
No!
Not me!
Oh shoot.
Looper?
Stop!
Shut up!
I'll go sailing!
Oh, I'm getting like flashbacks to my shoal.
Aw, me and Saba sang this together.
Bees.
Oh, that's not bees.
Where'd she go?
I'm dead.
That's where she go.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, I accidentally used one.
I didn't mean to though.
Because I pressed R to search again.
Shoot.
Just like before.
Be beyond the sea.
It's so catchy this thing though.
Bees.
You know what?
It's fine.
of the jazz show got got got to even more sailing solo oh
shoot oh sailing please okay you and then I need I need one
that goes up I need this one yes nice okay oh that was close
safe Safe, safe, safe.
Somewhere inside the bees.
Steel tip bolt.
We'll buy some.
Wait, I think I bought some before.
Buy some.
Buy some more.
Muchas gracias.
Where's my...
Did I hit the max?
You guys, I hit the max number of...
I think I hit the max number.
Okay, time to start at the very bottom.
Look how many I did in Neptune's bounty.
Wait.
Oh.
I'm loaded!
Okay, let's do that again.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, wow.
All I got to do is do it again.
No, no big deal.
Oh, my God.
Hello.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
Girl, you are on a roll tonight.
I don't know what's...
I know what's wrong.
with me i'm i'm a little overworked everybody i'm a little
at my limit
i'm a little overworked but i'm here i'm just i'm vibing
we're just here for a time please oh gosh this might be
tough wait this might be really hard wait can i get any more
upies please Yeah, there we go.
Um...
Woo!
Uh...
One more?
Oh, you bastard.
Oh, you hate me.
This is not even solvable.
Cruel.
This is not even like...
Game cheats.
Oh,
no, no!
Wait, uh, wait, wait, wait, this is- this is possible,
potentially.
Potentially.
Possible.
I need uppies.
I need ovaries.
Not ovaries.
Oh my god.
That's not what I meant to say.
You know what I- You guys know what I meant to- What I meant
with that word?
Hi!
You guys know what I meant?
Like because up ease?
And then when you go over, it's like over ease.
I should really think before I speak...
Oh, that's a...
Purchase?
I got the steel ball.
run and I got machine gun rounds okay shut up save Wow I
didn't hit the max number of save you guys I was all it was
a ruse a bamboozled you yeah steel ball run what do you got
nothing we're in Le Marquis de Epoch
Oh, yeah.
Better to just roll with it.
I think it's really funny when you don't think before you
speak.
But then it leads to silly nonsense!
Wait.
Oh my god, wait, is this solvable?
Is this?
I will do my darndest.
Oh my gosh, what is going on here?
Okay, and then at least it's slow.
What the hell?
It is solvable!
Baby!
Did you raid me?
Everything is cursed tonight!
There we go, thank you so much for the fine gift!
Thank you, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you, thank you!
I hope you had fun with Nemi!
I hope you had fun!
I'm gonna search again.
$11.
They're like, that's all you get.
Take it or leave it.
Guys, my brain is a little messed up tonight.
I keep pressing load instead of save and I keep pressing...
I keep saying things that I don't mean.
Everything is cursed.
Thank you guys for the gift ends.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
Whoa.
That guy scooped me.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I thought there was gonna be a...
What's it called?
I'm playing!
Me!
Oh!
That the weapons upgrade!
Boy, awesome.
Some Iron Betty tried to sell me on those fancy oxford club
cities.
No thanks.
I told her I'm a nickel-time man.
Always will be.
Why?
Oh.
Oh!
I clicked the bees.
Sorry.
Ah!
I can't see anything!
Did the bees happen?
Did they work?
Where is she?
Oh, I got her.
Nice.
Oh.
Everything is happening.
I didn't...
I truly didn't hear that.
Wait, it has a code.
7774.
Okay.
It has a code.
7774.
What should we upgrade?
I haven't used my pistol in a while.
Let's do the shotgun.
The rate of fire.
And also, everybody joining in?
Please?
If you haven't read the pinned message already?
Do so.
Thank you very much.
I'm having a special night, everybody.
And it's all because it's special because you're here.
Someone's setting off the alarms.
I don't know what alarm.
Okay, so we got everything in here.
Oh, in here?
Bees.
Ouch!
Not me!
Wait, why me?
Why me?
Maybe they won't find me here.
That guy moved.
Oh wait, I'm leading them to a...
Four.
Three.
Two.
One!
Why
did that happen?
I thought...
Bees.
Ouch!
Oops, I used another one.
I keep...
Ugh, I use another kit on accident.
That's okay.
We're back to the beast.
Mint isn't on screen, she's behind you.
I'm right behind you.
So because I accidentally broke, uh, oh my god, my, the, um,
window, that's why they went after me, because I did a
crime.
What?
I didn't press that.
The next thing I know, I'm called in the Raya's office to
talk about the whole mess.
Goddamn nutjob artists.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Crazy guys.
Alright, so we gotta go to Poseidon.
Bees.
Oh, oh!
Oh damn, that was so good.
Where is a Poseidon?
The seahore?
What's she doing to that guy?
Oh Poseidon, here we go.
Do I have fire?
Yes.
creepy you have violated the windows 11 what does that mean
can i get it the ice man cometh oh i can ah the ice man
cometh i'll panic like rabbits i just watched and waited And
when they started to kick, I started to scavenge.
Made myself a little splicer cocktail I did.
Where?
You can't come in from the cold.
And you gotta grow ice over your heart.
And the Iceman cometh, Sander, baby.
The Iceman fucking cometh.
Fighter of the Fireman.
Ah!
I'll eat those.
I guess fire would be good here, huh?
Oh.
Big daddy.
Where'd he go?
Hmm.
Curious.
Can I go up here?
Nice.
I got the high ground.
Where'd he go?
Yeah, where did that guy go?
Let's check it out.
Maybe I shouldn't unfreeze these guys.
Wait, can I, like, whack them?
Whack!
Oh, whack!
Wait, that's just the freeze.
But I have a feeling that they are all going to defrost.
You know what I mean?
Woo!
Did I get him?
Oh, I saw him though, for a second.
For a split second I saw him.
Where did he go?
So if I get him now, then I won't have to deal with them
later, perhaps.
Oh no, I don't think I got him fast enough.
This guy I was able to kill.
Ah!
I'm frozen!
Wait, what happened to me?
If you're a grapevine, save someone.
Son of a bitch.
Excuse me?
Oh!
Ouch!
Excuse me!
Oh.
Oh, flashbang.
That was fun.
Mm-hmm.
Break out the camera!
Thank you.
Real time cutscene glitches.
Wait, it glitched?
No, stinking way.
I honestly couldn't tell at all.
Nice action shot is what it says.
Sport boost.
In today's dangerous time, it never hurts to be a little
faster.
A little quicker on the draw.
Remember, you don't have to outrun the craze splicer.
Just your neighbor.
That's so terrible.
You move and swing the wrench faster.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Wait.
So if I take another one.
Oh.
And one more?
Yeah, great for wrench build if I did that.
Increase damage!
So if I try one more, what will happen?
Oh, okay.
Just a smaller amount.
Let's get a good shot of you.
Oh, that's a nice one.
Wow.
And one more.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
More damage.
And another one.
Lee.
You're supposed to freeze and NPC walks around you, but
since you unfroze that dude, he was bopping you out of the
way, so you never saw the guy.
Wait.
I'm not supposed to attack these guys.
Oh,
increased damage.
Nitro splicers are vulnerable to...
Oh, yeah, yeah, I know.
I have no idea what's going on, but...
Whatever, it's fine.
I'm just getting points for it all.
This train really is cursed.
Holy cow.
Oh!
Ow!
Please!
No!
Ouch!
Oh!
I stink and died.
No!
Where is the Vida chamber at?
Oh, okay.
It's right outside.
That's not bad.
Oop.
Please.
That
was freezing.
Take a photo of him.
Oh!
Oh, this is the guy!
I'm feeling full like an expectant mama.
Ew!
Oh, I didn't realize he was like a special guy.
Yes, now put the picture in the frame.
Let's see what we've got here.
Frozen field.
Leave your toes.
No, sorry.
Oh,
in the cold!
You take less damage from cold and you can freeze enemies
when you hit them with the wrench!
Oh, wait, that's kind of awesome!
I think I'll put it in the gene bank for now, though.
Because I don't really use my wrench.
Streamer is as scuffed as the stream.
I don't know what to tell you guys.
Oh, can I take a picture of this guy?
Does he count?
These guys are all...
No!
The photos!
Aw, let...
Wait, where'd they go then?
Wait, that's kind of terrifying.
Wait, where did they go then?
What?
Yes.
Oh, toes!
It's fine, we're hacking.
Uh...
Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
What is it?
My computer is trying to...
My computer is trying to communicate with me.
Uh...
Actually, let's just go like that, yeah.
And then...
I don't know if I'll make this one.
Yeah, I did not have enough long boys to make it, sadly.
I'm even going to load this one because I don't have so many
health kits right now.
Long boy shortage.
So sad.
You win some, you lose some.
It's the luck of the draw.
Oh, the luck of the draw, the luck of the draw.
Wow, so many up there.
I feel like I'm short-circuiting, like my brain is giving
up.
Now I know there's that door over there and I will save
before I go in it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, big daddy's in here.
Oh, it's the other design!
It's this guy!
Yippee!
I like this one so much more.
He looks so cool.
Oh, shoot.
I don't want to deal with you.
Go, go, go.
I'm leaving.
Taki, thank you!
Minto should be invisible more if she speaks like this.
What the hell?
What am I saying?
put your photo on the thing.
Hi, dang.
Bees.
What the?
I tried to shoot?
That wasn't my fault.
I didn't even let the bees get to him.
Love how you make even technical issues entertaining.
I'm glad you think so.
Thank you.
There was somebody there.
Wow!
This one's great!
I could never stomach doubters.
I don't doubt you.
This is fun.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
My first pick got mangled.
Oh yeah, what happened there?
What happened there?
Why?
Bees.
Maybe, okay, so now where do I go?
We went to the Poseidon.
Oh, okay.
What happened?
There we go.
Zoom out.
Did he say where?
Do I have to go through Poseidon?
Frozen tunnel.
Hmm.
Okay.
Can you highlight another objective?
Oh, yeah, let's try it.
Oh!
Kill Silas Cobb.
But there's no arrow.
I don't want to do this part because I'm afraid I'm gonna...
Okay, wait.
Let's...
Fire.
Because I feel like I'm gonna accidentally aggro Bigaddy.
Is he still here anymore?
Or maybe he's gone.
No, I hear him.
But I don't see the...
I don't see the other guy.
I hear the other guy.
Wait, where'd she go?
Okay, I think she's fighting with somebody else.
Cool.
Anyway, I'm hacking.
He'll be alright.
You think so?
Oh, tough one.
Oh, it's fast, it's fast, it's fast.
I need an up piece.
I need the other way, please.
Oh, no, no, that one makes it go fast.
Oh, no, wait.
I need up.
No, no, I need the one that...
Oh, here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yes, saveable.
Ah!
I totally, I fumbled that hard, that was my bad.
Oh, oh, I had it, I had it.
I did have it, that was my bad.
She fumbles, she fumbles.
Dang, first try to like, getting it.
Upies, upies, any upies, any more upies?
Oh, oh my gosh, game, don't do that.
to me please not right now.
I'm still a rest.
Yahoo!
Oh, they're right there.
She's in front of the circus of values.
She's purchasing values.
What do you need with values, little girl?
You're like five years old.
What do you need with values?
In a pretty quiet.
The reason I'm hesitant right now is because I know there
was like a splicer on the ceiling.
I just don't know where she went.
I don't want her ambushing me and accidentally aggrowing
him.
The mall.
We're at the mall.
Oh my god.
What's going on in here?
Holy hell.
What do you mean the machine I just attacked is friendly?
The machine you just hacked is now friendly.
Game!
Found her.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I thought I was on my shotgun.
When did I switch to this?
Oh.
Oh there's two of them.
Oh my god, please!
Okay, I'm...
Any more?
I just realized is that a security camera?
Oh my god, they won't stop coming.
They don't stop coming.
They don't
stop coming.
Holy hell
Here he comes!
Don't step on the fire.
Sorry I made a bit of a mess.
Sorry.
Don't worry about the mess.
So sorry.
Wow, that was a lot of them, wasn't it?
Holy hell.
I think I'm reaching my limit with the stinking controls,
though.
I will check for tomorrow and see if it's...
if it's normal or not.
And if it's not!
I might reconsider playing tomorrow, we'll see.
What's the music being sad for?
What happened?
Oh, it's slot machines.
Yippie.
What's that sound?
It's like, boop, boop.
Fontaine knew our blokes were coming.
We were done over.
Then splices come screaming out the woodwork.
Burp in fire, spitting ice.
Demons out of the Bible they were.
I've never seen nothing like it.
It wasn't a business he was building.
It was an army.
Splices.
Let's try getting this bad boy.
Oh!
Tuffy.
Um...
Wait, no.
These are...
This one.
Ah!
Shoot!
Oh my gosh, it's so fast!
What the hell?
Let's see.
Yes!
Yeah!
Yeah, that's the good stuff.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Wait, I need one that goes the other direction?
Heal.
And then heal.
Oh yeah!
Mm-hmm.
where am I?
Yeah, I know.
Things are not really working in my favor today.
You have a knack for untying those tubes.
I love hacking so much.
I love hacking.
I'm really sorry though that I, that today has been such a
flop.
I don't know what at all is going on.
I'm gonna gamble my money away.
Apples, apples, apples.
Oh, come on.
I think that's the first one I've lost.
I can hack it.
It's disabled, though.
What good is it to me?
You are nothing to me.
Trap walk.
Wait, does that mean what I think it is?
Like, I can shoot these now?
It'll reawaken as a friend if you hack it.
Really?
I'll try.
Oh, oh.
I don't think I've tried...
Wait, no, I don't know if I've tried this one before.
Like, it being here.
I don't recognize it.
Oh, look at that!
Oh, it's one of these!
that's why I thought it was a oh oh he's all better I
thought it was uh one of the shooty not not the drones but
like a shooty oh he's a little stupid he's a little dumb we
love him though
oh thank you for taking care of us
I said what I said
I said what I said Yeah He was like He was like Why did you
bring me back I think he truly was like Wanting to You know
Don't take the money Oh my gosh You can't just put money in
there though Rapture records Look at this
Wow what a
scene oh cop here it is corner on the car there's voices
everywhere I keep playing even though I say I'm like at my
limit because I do have fun with this It is fun game.
Ryan's stable boy.
Ryan's corrupt policies crab all over the place.
And Cohen flutters around clearing it up.
But instead of using a shovel like you would with a proper
mule, it is fun game.
And a clever turn of phrase.
But no matter how the game doesn't frustrate me, it's the
technical issues.
Ew!
Is it all the crap?
Not the issue.
Is this our guy?
Uh oh.
I had a feeling.
Please.
Holy.
What's happening?
What's coming out?
Ah!
Oh!
Ouch!
Where are you?
Oh shoot.
No way, I'm out.
Damn, this sucks.
We'll go to Shotty.
Oh my god.
How are they already on fire?
What's that?
Oh, take that, thank you.
Maybe I don't need the fire then.
Peace.
Hold on, what?
Sometimes they reap the skin.
Maybe.
Oh.
You know what?
I'll use it.
And then we'll grab it.
And then we'll save it.
Sorry.
Don't mean to me.
Everybody was thinking that, no?
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh.
Oh, nice.
This place is really dark.
Oh, in here!
Oh, the gamer painted me.
They were like, follow the light!
Dummy?
Oh, it's just a bear.
Oh.
And where is it?
Fees.
Where are you?
Oh my god Bees Not bees Bees Bees Oh shoot Did I break a Oh
my god no No no no I didn't mean to I'm not trying to Oh
Trying to run I promised Ouch
Oh did I get him I can't hear you over the alarm The blaring
sounds
Oh take a photo where'd I blat oh there he is um is there a
thing to shut this up oh my god no no no they're coming for
me they're coming for me no they're coming for me two one
they give up
oh we're fine whoa we're okay we're okay we're okay there
must have been the wind let's hack this real quick so i
don't i don't like them to use it you know what i mean my
hands only this is for your eyes only oh thank you god uh if
wait oh yeah we're going a little bit of a funky ways but
that's okay Funky, funky, funky town.
Funky, funky, funky night.
I keep pressing 5 thinking it's...
Wait, oh.
Hopefully no one's there.
Oh.
I'll take what you got.
And I'll get a real nice photo of you.
Nice.
Wow, that one came out horribly.
You can't see anything.
taking life as you go you're not a moth you're an angel i've
met maybe i should i like how the spotlight follows us it's
kind of funny that's fun
let's just go he doesn't notice me right oh oh Uh, please.
Oh, my god.
Alright.
Oh, no.
I switched back.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm at my limit.
The...
It's so annoying.
It's so...
I'm gonna put this picture up, and then...
Oh, my god.
I can't...
I can't do anything.
Without it clicking out of the window.
I'm so done.
sorry guys I'm so sorry it's so annoying
is there fall damage in this for real
I wanted to at least get through all the photos these are
fine by anyone screw you screw all you fucking doubters
here's what I say to all of you oh no prize this time oh no
prize Oh no wait, no this will get me copyright struck.
NONO!
This will get me copyright struck for real please!
No, no, no, no, no.
No, please!
It will get me copyright struck!
No, I ride!
This happened before!
No, please!
Bees.
It's happened!
Ah, what about!
Bees, ow.
Where are they?
Bees.
Ouch!
Holy hell.
Uh, can I switch?
Exploding electric.
Please.
I think I was about to die.
Oh, ouch.
And you guys don't kill me!
They...
Oh my god, it's getting louder.
No!
This game, I promise!
I promise that it's not me!
Am I done?
Did I complete it?
Pause and mute.
Oh, that's a great idea.
I'm muted.
No, I can enjoy the music, but sorry, you can't.
Bees.
I don't think that they...
Oh, I did it, though.
Oh, my God.
That was the last guy.
That was it.
You'll have to forgive an old fool his artistic temperament.
The birth is so close now.
The labor pains can blur the judgment and drive the passions
of even the finest spirits.
Yeah, I don't remember which game it was, but they played
that song.
And, um...
I, yeah, YouTube was just like, no ma'am.
We will not allow this.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, I'll take that.
Oh, awesome.
Nice!
Not nice.
Loot box?
It's basically a loot box.
Can I turn...
Can I do this now?
What was it?
7774 or something?
But sadly, it won't let me even try.
It won't let me even attempt.
We'll have to remember it for next time, I suppose.
Look at you.
Is it being all sexy for me like that?
Oh, damn.
Bees.
Oh.
They were afraid.
And they were right to be afraid.
Okay guys, I think I'll stop here just because game is
silly.
Everything is silly.
My mind is silly.
The computer is silly.
The game is silly.
I can't take it anymore!
I'm so sorry.
everything was so scuffed today and i didn't make so much
progress but um i still had fun i hope you guys did too uh
and thank you so much for hanging out with me and when
everything is silly everything is so silly ah we will get
the last guy next time and continue onwards tomorrow
hopefully yeah not to apologize for things out of your
control has gotten progressively worse your stream lagged
yeah we'll just we'll just call it here thank you for the
streaming don't don't go thank you so much for the pink
thank you don't leave your toes out in the cold oh we had a
pretty silly time didn't we yeah it was pretty silly wasn't
it thank you we don't even if nothing went to play it was
super fun it's always a joy spending time with you well guys
don't forget to smash that like button and lick that
subscribe and i'll see you next time mint apply our channel
stay you're a chupravito thank you get some rest all right
yeah yeah i will
try princess thank you i don't know if you're there it is
don't need to apologize it's not your fault thank you thank
you always for the lovely streams happy eyes and fun i'll
see you when i see you next
luck fixing the problems for tomorrow yeah i will i will i
will work on it before stream and let you guys know my uh
slurp that join button ew i'll let you guys know of my uh
progress and everything how it goes hopefully tomorrow i'm
just i'm back on screen you can see me game runs perfectly
everything is okie-dokie honky-dory fake me thank you
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, see you, bye, bye, bye, yeah,
bye, yeah, bye, I forgot
that I turned it on, oh, sorry, I'm after the stream, when I
was talking to you guys earlier,